good afternoon let's start with that
breaking news from liverpool a 14 year
old boy found guilty of the murder of
school girl ava white the 12 year old
was stabbed while out with friends in
liverpool in november last year we go
live to becky cotterell who's at
liverpool crown court to tell us more
becky
yeah it was an extremely emotional
moment in court when that verdict was
read out a guilty verdict for murder her
family and friends ava's family um they
screamed they were crying there's been a
large group of family and friends here
throughout this trial this is the
verdict they've been hoping for and you
could see the relief you know her mum
shaking as that verdict was read out it
took the jury just over two hours
to reach a guilty verdict for murder ava
white was stabbed in the neck uh in
november november 25th she was in town
with friends for the turning on of the
christmas lights and we were told
throughout the trial about the events
that led up to her being stabbed she had
been in town with her friends and they
bumped into another group the
defendant's group of friends he is a 14
year old boy that we cannot name for
legal reasons and a dispute had broken
out because the defendant and his
friends were filming ava and her group
they were kind of looking about lying on
the floor having a good time they didn't
like the fact that they were being
filmed they'd asked the defendant and
his friends to delete that footage and
that is where the conflict had broken
out now the defendant had admitted to
possessing a knife but he had said that
he had stabbed ava in self-defense now
clearly the jury didn't believe that and
that's why they found him guilty of
murder
throughout this trial we've been shown
cctv footage of the events that night
including the moment that ava was
stabbed she was taken to hospital
afterwards but died from her injuries
and the prosecution characterizing how
that defendant that 14 year old boy had
behaved afterwards they said at best he
was utterly unconcerned and at worst he
was quite pleased with himself
because he felt big now the defendant
appeared throughout this trial via video
link uh he can't be named for legal
reasons and he was able to appear
remotely because of his age when that
verdict was read out in court he put his
head in his hands and he stayed with his
head in his hands for quite a while the
prosecution said during the trial that
he had covered up his tracks by lying
about his whereabouts that night denying
that he was even there concealing
evidence including the coat that he was
wearing and trying to blame someone else
before finally admitting that he had
been there and admitting that he'd
stabbed ava
and we were shown hours of cctv and that
is something that the cps when i spoke
to them earlier talked about the kind of
difficulty in going through all this
cctv to present it to the court the cps
also spoke about
the tragic nature of this case the fact
that the defendants are so young and
here uh is uh claire chicony from the
cps this is what she told me earlier
i think the worrying thing for people
dealing with this case was the age of
the victim and the age of the defendant
but also that there were a number of
other children present during the
incident so it was a it was a massive
concern it's obviously had devastating
effects
for everybody involved
and that that's what the cps were really
keen to talk about the devastating
impact on this case obviously primarily
on ava's family but also on the children
who witnessed the events that night and
of course on the defendant himself he is
just a 14 year old boy and i know that
ava's family have been very keen to talk
about knife crime in the past but that
is the thing to take away from this the
fact that a 14 year old boy was in town
with a knife and a 12 year old girl was
stabbed to death
becky that's utterly tragic and becky
crusher thank you